Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Stefania Betti
Avete mai provato
a non riuscire a definire
una relazione che,
diciamo così, diventa intima?
O avete fatto l'esperienza
di non riuscire a riconoscere
una persona con cui state
in coppia da tempo,
e sentirla come estranea?
Oppure, vi siete mai chiesti
se state con una persona in coppia
perché realmente vi interessa,
o per noia, per abitudine?
Avete mai pensato, provato ad avere
più di una relazione di coppia
nello stesso momento?
Sono domande importanti,
nella nostra società,
che non riguardano soltanto
le relazioni intime,
ma anche le relazioni sociali.
Io sono una psicologa,
psicoterapeuta della Gestalt,
mi occupo di formazione
alla psicoterapia da 40 anni,
sia in Italia che all'estero.
Dal mio punto di vista
vi parlerò della coppia
secondo un aspetto importante
e ancora poco esplorato,
che è la sincronia.
Cioè il modo di essere in coppia
come una danza, con reciprocità.
Vi parlerò della reciprocità della coppia.
Cos'è la sincronia?
La sincronia è la capacità
di rispondere all'altro
in un tempo abbastanza breve
da creare una ritmicità
dell'uno con l'altro,
da creare una danza.
La sincronia è qualcosa
che oggi è importante,
e nasce già nelle relazioni primarie.
Già nelle prime relazioni
dei genitori con il bambino,
nei primi giorni di vita,
si dà l'avvio a quella che poi sarà
la sincronia, o la reciprocità,
nelle relazioni del bambino.
Più c'è sincronia, più il bambino riesce
a regolare l'arousal,
ovvero la crescita dell'eccitazione
nelle cose che fa,
sia che siano accompagnate
da paura o da gioia.
I vocalizzi della mamma
calmano il bambino,
e lo fanno radicare anche nella relazione.
Più c'è sincronia,
più c'è senso dell'alleanza
in una relazione.
Più c'è sincronia, e più c'è
il senso della sicurezza di sé.
Quindi la sincronia consente di essere
più sicuri e radicati in se stessi,
e anche di potere affrontare
le situazioni stressanti della vita
in modo autonomo.
Tutte le ricerche psicologiche
e neuro-scientifiche, in questi anni,
ci portano a descrivere le relazioni
come relazioni in cui il nostro sé
nasce e cresce all'interno
di relazioni significative.
Il nostro cervello è fatto
nella relazione e per la relazione.
In particolare,
sembra che il nostro cervello
sia sensibile al movimento dell'altro.
Il bambino, per esempio,
riconosce la madre
non tanto dai singoli dettagli del volto,
ma da tutto l'insieme dei dettagli
che vengono armonizzati in un movimento.
Quindi, noi siamo sensibili
all'armonia in movimento dell'altro.
E anche noi rispondiamo
al movimento dell'altro
con un nostro movimento:
ci intenzioniamo verso l'altro
in un modo creativo,
dando luogo ad una danza unica,
fatta del movimento dell'altro
e del movimento nostro.
Questo movimento, quindi,
è la sede della danza della coppia,
della reciprocità;
ma anche la sede della nascita del sé.
Noi nasciamo, il nostro sé -
cioè senso di chi siamo -
nasce all'interno
di relazioni significative
e in più possiamo dire che nasce
all'interno di un movimento,
del movimento che si apprende
all'interno della relazione.
Cosa cambia questo,
nel nostro modo di guardare la coppia?
Cambia nel fatto
che non siamo tanto interessati
ai significati relativi,
alle esperienze passate della coppia,
quando la coppia è in conflitto;
ma siamo più interessati a capire
cosa la coppia sperimenta
nel presente, in questo momento.
Quindi, se per esempio uno dice all'altro
"Ti odio, sei la rovina della mia vita",
ci interessa sapere
come dice questa frase,
quale è la sua esperienza
e soprattutto l'esperienza corporea.
Cosa sente nel corpo,
mentre dice all'altro questa cosa.
Questo è quello che noi chiamiamo
"atteggiamento fenomenologico".
Ma c'è anche un atteggiamento estetico,
che segue da quello che vi dicevo prima.
Cioè guardare l'altro
come se fosse un'opera d'arte.
Se proviamo a guardare l'altro,
che ci dice questa frase,
come se fosse un'opera d'arte,
mettiamo da parte le nostre ferite,
cioè ciò che ci aggancia.
E lo guardiamo con una certa
oggettività estetica
e quindi ci lasciamo affascinare
da qualcosa che ci colpisce.
Cosa ci affascina dell'altro?
Forse uno sguardo che ci può dire
qualcosa di particolare sul dolore,
e anche il desiderio dell'altro.
Allora dovremmo essere
tutti più addestrati
a guardare l'altro in modo estetico,
per potere capire una profondità
dell'esperienza dell'altro
che le parole non dicono.
Qualcosa che dice la sintesi,
la Gestalt appunto, del suo movimento.
Un'altra cosa che cambia
riguarda il guardare
l'interazione di coppia
come un campo, come qualcosa
che i due creano insieme.
La presenza dell'altro è come un sasso,
che cade nell'acqua e provoca
dei cerchi concentrici nell'acqua.
Siamo come l'acqua,
che ci facciamo modificare dall'altro,
quindi reagiamo all'altro, risuoniamo
a quello che l'altro fa o dice
con le nostre esperienze passate,
che possono essere
di fallimento o di successo.
Quindi, tra i due si crea
un gioco di sfondi e di figure.
Gli sfondi sono fatti
dalle nostre esperienze passate,
che poi si uniscono e si incontrano
nel confine di contatto presente,
del qui e ora che è un gioco
di desideri dei due.
Non sempre questa presenza
del confine di contatto
è chiara, è nitida.
A volte ci desensibilizziamo.
A volte non vediamo esattamente l'altro.
E la desensibilizzazione è qualcosa
che riguarda un po' la nostra società:
la nostra è una società desensibilizzata.
Che vuol dire?
Che dobbiamo alzare la soglia
della nostra sensibilità,
perché sentire le cose
diventa insopportabile.
Da dove viene questa difficoltà?
Molto, dalle condizioni in cui si cresce.
Oggi le condizioni
sono diverse rispetto a prima.
per esempio, la presenza dei genitori
è molto meno, rispetto ad anni fa.
Per cui il bambino ha meno
la presenza, lo sguardo del genitore,
il contenimento del genitore;
ci sono molti stimoli
a cui il bambino deve far fronte
ma poca possibilità
di chiudere le esperienze.
C'è molto "zapping":
si passa da un'esperienza all'altra
ma le esperienze non possono chiudersi,
allora è come il bambino rimanesse
in uno stato di perenne eccitazione,
e non si può rilasciare.
Questo è spiacevole,
e per adattamento creativo
il bambino si desensibilizza:
alza la soglia della propria sensibilità.
Questo succede anche agli adulti:
viviamo in un mondo desensibilizzato.
Cosa succede allora, cosa vuol dire questo
nel momento in cui, da adulto,
la persona si innamora
e deve gestire il desiderio dell'altro?
È difficile, perché è difficile
sentire il proprio corpo.
Perché è difficile
stare con l'altro a lungo,
il contatto con l'altro
diventa stressante.
È difficile anche avere
un terreno solido, un senso di sé solido,
per potersi lanciare
in qualcosa di nuovo con l'altro.
Quindi le relazioni di coppia
sono difficili per questo.
E rispondendo alle domande iniziali,
a volte ci chiediamo
se una relazione di coppia
è una relazione di coppia o meno,
perché è difficile sentire il corpo.
Oppure ci chiediamo se stare con l'altro
è realmente una cosa
che viene dal nostro desiderio o meno.
Oppure, non essendoci un senso
di radicamento nella relazione,
non chiediamo una relazione univoca,
e abbiamo più relazioni
contemporaneamente.
Questa è la situazione:
come possiamo fare, per [migliorarla]?
Nell'istituto che dirigo
con alcuni colleghi,
stiamo studiando
la reciprocità della coppia,
cioè cosa la coppia fa già bene insieme,
in che modo è sincrona,
e come possiamo sostenere questi aspetti
della coppia che funziona.
Quindi come possiamo sostenere
la reciprocità e la danza.
Ci sono tre cose che la coppia
fa bene insieme, quando funziona.
Uno è vedere l'altro come altro,
cioè riconoscere l'alterità dell'altro.
Il riconoscere che è diverso
e non cercare di cambiarlo,
stare con l'alterità.
La seconda cosa è riuscire a separare
l'effetto che quello che ci dice l'altro
ha su di noi, dalla sua intenzione.
Non sempre, quando l'altro
ci ferisce, vuole ferirci.
Quindi, riuscire a separare
ciò che noi sentiamo
da quello che l'altro,
effettivamente, intende fare con noi
è una qualità importante.
La terza cosa è il riuscire
a fare un salto nel vuoto,
cioè riuscire a mettere
le nostre ferite da parte
per vedere l'altro
e fare una cosa che piace all'altro.
Queste sono le tre caratteristiche
che riguardano un po' tutta la ricchezza,
il riconoscere l'alterità della persona.
Cosa fare quindi nella pratica,
nella nostra pratica quotidiana?
Vi inviterei a pensare
ad una persona che voi amate,
e a pensare al movimento tipico
di questa persona che voi amate:
Qual è il movimento?
Pensatelo,
e quando avete tempo, magari disegnatelo.
Un'altra cosa che potete fare,
per capire la sincronia
della vostra relazione di coppia
è chiedere ad un amico di guardarvi
mentre decidete qualcosa insieme,
per esempio dove andare in vacanza.
E poi chiedetegli di dirvi
come vede la vostra relazione,
come vede la vostra danza,
come la descriverebbe
da un punto di vista estetico.
Un'altra cosa che potete fare
è trovare insieme due, tre cose
che sapete fare bene,
e poi chiedervi: che cosa sento,
quando faccio questa cosa bene
insieme all'altro?
Per esempio fare la spesa,
una cosa molto banale.
Quando faccio la spesa con lui,
la faccio bene perché mi sento libera,
penso di potere scegliere
tutto quello che voglio.
Pensate ora il momento difficile:
che cosa dovrebbe fare l'altro
perché voi vi possiate sentirvi così bene,
perché voi possiate sentirvi liberi?
Per esempio,
l'altro dovrebbe farvi un sorriso
o dirvi quella frase
che mi fa sentire libera.
Ecco: se riuscite ad individuare
questa cosa magica,
che la persona può fare con voi,
è un grande aiuto.
E una terza cosa che potete fare
è pensare all'altro come una persona
che voi amate e che non vi ha mai ferito.
Pensate all'altro
come se non vi avesse mai ferito
e ditegli che cosa vi ha fatto innamorare,
cioè quale è stata la cosa,
quel dolore che la persona ha forgiato
e che vi rende forti,
vi dà la forza, il coraggio,
per raggiungerlo con il vostro amore,
come se fossero
due opere d'arte intrecciate.
La cosa importante da imparare,
nella relazione di coppia,
è la reciprocità.
La reciprocità è qualcosa
che va al di là
dei significati individuali.
Può aiutare molto la relazione di coppia,
ed è una reciprocità
che è fatta di tante cose:
dalle reazioni personali
ma molto anche, dalla vitalità
delle due persone che stanno bene insieme.
Quindi un problema di coppia
non è mai dovuto
a uno dei due singolarmente,
ma è sempre dovuto a qualcosa che accade
nella danza, nella loro reciprocità.
In questo modo, quindi,
se ognuno di noi vede le proprie ferite
come se fossero un'opera d'arte,
allora l'altro può vibrare
davanti alle nostre ferite
come se fossero un'opera d'arte.
Può intrecciare il capolavoro
della propria vita con la vita dell'altro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)